[Music]
the big news tonight historic night
right
yeah
the first
president you don't know what i'm going
to say the first
presidential debate between president
obama and mitt romney i said written
britt momney
i blame the pirate
it's tonight this is the beginning this
is hot we're finally getting down to the
wire yeah yeah yeah in preparation for
tonight's debate mitt romney has
reportedly this is in the news
reportedly been practicing his zingers
he's practicing zingers yeah romney said
he couldn't wait to use his best zinger
your mama is so poor she only makes 250
000 a year
i want to hear him doing your mama joke
except
your mother yeah
i love these your mother jokes why i've
looked into it and your mother
it's being reported that mitt romney's
goal for tonight's debate is to make
barack obama look like jimmy carter
that's what they're saying yeah
meanwhile barack obama's goal tonight is
to make mitt romney look like mitt
romney
so it's going to be a strategy
[Applause]
[Music]
that impression's catching on yeah yeah
you know what's interesting today was
not only the first presidential debate
it was also president obama's 20th
wedding anniversary
yeah i think the president got a little
confused because at one point he told
michelle she was out of touch with the
middle class and romney that he looks as
beautiful as the day they first met
they embraced which was that that was
beautiful yeah
it might not be a mistake
president obama is winning the election
according to an informal poll conducted
by 7-eleven
that's true
however the findings are being hotly
contested by analysts from the
cheesecake factory
so more on that later
why is 7-eleven taking a poll i you know
what i actually was at a 7-eleven and i
think it's like how whatever coffee cup
they had obama coffee cups and romney
coffee cups and depending on which one
you choose right how many of whichever
one sold i think i myself made my own
ross perot cup
you wrote it out i wrote it out
and i insisted they'd take note of it
if enough people would do that we'd get
this country back on track all right
a recent survey
says that many women over the age of 65
think that joe biden is sexy
joe biden yeah
so now when your grandma asks for a hot
cup of joe she might not be asking for
coffee
get me a hot cup with yo
i'm sorry that was a prospector
i'm an old lady
yeah i'm you always going to get that
gold
i have a narrow range
it's being reported that a radio shack a
radio shack sold a teenage girl a cell
phone that already had pornographic
pictures on it
in a related story the radio shack cell
phone is now outselling the new iphone
10 to one
these people yeah
hey mister can i get one of them porn
phones
the government has released the names of
dozens of products containing fraudulent
weight loss claims
yeah
some of the products include bacon flex
and the ab couch
both products i want by the way
i want the bacon flecks i want them both
yeah christmas is coming
shocking births in the united states
births have fallen for the fourth year
in a row
yeah
experts blame this on the poor economy
and fear of another honey boo-boo
is that scary
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]